hello there so we have been given a new
look at andor in the form of three newly
released images so let's break it down
in the first new imagery we have mon
mothma and luff and rail which is a new
character it looks like they're in a
museum of some kind we can see a lot of
artifacts it looks like in the bottom
right corner here we have something that
looks like a mandalorian chest plate
behind my mother that could also be a
wookie warrior mask and finally at the
back right corner it looks like a calico
which we have seen in star wars rebels
in the next two images we have andor and
this lady which is a new character we
have not seen her in star wars before
both of these places and environments
they are in seem to be new places that
we have not seen in star wars before i
think i remember my memory serves me
correct there was interviews for andor
and they said we're going to see new
locations and planets in this show so i
would say these locations are entirely
new places and if there's another thing
we can break down from these images is
that everything looks very authentic and
grounded as i've said in my previous
videos and or is the best looking star
wars tv show at least visually
everything just looks pretty much like a
star wars film and also the first season
is going to be 12 episodes so they've
really put a lot of care and time and
effort into this show which makes me a
bit upset that i didn't do the same for
kenobi because that show i'm sorry to
say it does look cheap in some aspects
and that was only about six episodes
long whereas this is double that anyway
that is everything for this breakdown so
if you did enjoy please leave a like and
comment if you would like more
breakdowns like this and if you haven't
already please subscribe to stay up to
date with new videos thanks for watching
guys